All right. Good morning, everyone, and thank you
for being here. I hope you're enjoying
AACR so far. Lots of good stuff.
But welcome to the Advances in Diagnostics and
Therapeutics session
on synthetic lethality in oncology, progress made,
pitfalls encountered,
and the path forward. So we all know that
targeting synthetic lethal interactions offers
potential therapeutic strategies
for cancers with alterations in pathways that might otherwise
be considered undruggable. And really spurred by the
clinical success of PARP inhibitors in
patients with BRCA mutation cancers,
novel therapies targeting multiple different
synthetic lethal interactions are currently in clinical
development, and also rational strategies targeting synthetic
lethal interactions spanning different alterations in epigenetic,
metabolic, and proliferative pathways have also emerged.
So we're in for a real treat today. We have
Mark O'Connor, the chief scientist from
AstraZeneca, but who's really someone who's been involved
with PARP inhibitor development from the very early days.
I see Graham Smith there when they were at Kudos
with Steve Jackson when Olaparib was still known as
KU0059436, and
Mark and Graham were much, much younger as well, and so was I.
But we're going to hear about the whole evolution of
PARP inhibitor development from the PARP1/2
inhibitors to now the new generation
PARP1-selective agents. And then I'll speak about the
challenges and
give you some hard truths on what we're seeing in the clinic on
synthetic lethal
opportunities and strategies, but also
promising approaches, how we're now tackling things
like predictive biomarkers of response, the therapeutic
index, and also thinking about novel rational combinations,
some data
which I presented a couple of days ago here at this AACR meeting.
And then to finish things off,
thank you, Steve, for being here.
Steve Allen is the CSO at Falcon
Therapeutics,
who have certainly a nice pipeline of very novel
synthetic lethality
agents. And Steve is going to talk about leveraging paralog
relationships for targeting chromatin modulators in
cancer. And in particular, he's going to be covering targeting
ARID1A mutation cancers with ARID1B degraders
and also novel combinations for
SMARCA2 inhibitors and SMARCA4
mutation cancers. So without further ado, I want to
introduce Mark O'Connor from AstraZeneca. Thanks for being here, Mark.
Thanks.
Just before Mark starts,
please feel free to submit your questions.
We will hold questions till the end, and we're going to have a
panel discussion. So any difficult questions can go to these two gentlemen next to
me. All right, over to you, Mark. Thank you.
Yeah. Thanks a lot. It's great to be here.
These are my disclosures.
And really what I'm going to talk about today are the learnings from
the use of PARP inhibitors in HRD cancer.
So to date, it's the only successful example where synthetic
lethality has actually
been turned into cancer medicines.
And obviously the original synthetic lethality approaches in Drosophila and then
later yeast were genetic, where the impairment of two genes
together leads to cell death, but where the impairment of either
one alone is compatible with survival.
Now, obviously, in cancer therapy, what we're doing is replacing one of those
genetic components with a pharmacological inhibitor
but still trying to exploit a tumor-specific deficiency.
And the DNA damage response, so DDR, has really been the focus of
much of the synthetic lethality approaches so far,
primarily because it's a hallmark of cancer.
And essentially, every cancer will have lost one or more DDR
capability,
coupled with the fact that there are multiple pathways that deal with different
types of damage, and you can have a scenario in
DDR where the loss of one DDR capability can at least be compensated
for by another pathway. So in terms of
trying to exploit that with inhibitors, on the right, what you
can see here is essentially a scenario where two DDR
pathways, A and B, have the potential to compensate for each other, and where
in the cancer where it's lost pathway A and is now dependent on B, we
can target that with a small molecule inhibitor and induce cancer cell death.
Whereas in the normal tissue, there would still be pathway A to provide that
compensation.
So I'm showing here on the left and the right essentially DDR,
where you have multiple different types of damage, and you have different pathways
that can deal with that. For example, one of the most common
forms of DNA damage is single-strand breaks, tens of thousands every day per cell.
And the base excision repair pathway will deal with that, where PARP is involved.
And the most cytotoxic
form of DNA damage, DNA double-strand breaks.
You can see there are multiple pathways to try and deal with that.
So in an ideal scenario, if you have a replicated
DNA sister chromatid, you can use that as an undamaged template.
It's accurate. It's efficient. And then there are also
error-prone pathways, microhomology end joining,
and non-homologous end joining.And it's really important that
during the cell cycle, there's an opportunity to try and repair the damage
before going into the next phase. So we know that cancers will
essentially have all lost a G1S checkpoint capability.
So there's a greater dependency in cancers on the intra-S
checkpoints and also their G2M and intra-M
checkpoints as well. And if we look at the DDR proteins that have
primarily been the focus of small molecule inhibitor approaches,
you can see that that includes PARP, which has a role in both single-strand break
and double-strand break, but also ATM, ATR, Pol Q or Pol
theta, which is involved in MMEJ. And you can see
roles for ATR in intra-S phase, but also importantly, these
potential targets, BRCA1 and WE1, that are involved in the G2M checkpoint.
Now, early indications were that DDR dependencies
could be targeted.
Some of the very early work came from Steve Jackson's work with Simon Bolton,
carried out this experiment. And here what you can see is sensitivity
to radiation treatment.
You don't have a huge increase in sensitization if you knock out NHEJ,
the Ligase IV or Ku70 proteins in yeast.
There's a greater dependency on RAD52, which is involved in homologous
recombination repair in yeast. But you can see that if you take out both
the HR and the NHEJ, you get a significant
increase in sensitization.
And some of the early work that was done in Steve's lab with Rebecca Isard and
Graham Smith
demonstrated you could identify and use inhibitors of DDR
proteins in order to generate sensitization.
And as Tim mentioned, that led to the formation of the very first company to focus
on targeting DDR in cancer, which was Kudos.
And you can see actually how young we really were then.
So Graham looks a bit younger too.
He's now the CSO of RTS, and Neil Smith went on to be the CEO of RTS.
So it was really a collaboration between Kudos, who at that
time had generated pro PARP inhibitors, and Alan Ashworth's group at
the ICR that led to this discovery,
co-discovery I should say, of the sensitivity of
BRCA deficient cells to PARP inhibitors.
So, back-to-back publications from Kudos and Ashworth
lab, and also Nicola Curtin in Newcastle and Thomas Helleday
in Sheffield. And basically what you can see here
are mouse ES cells that are knocked out for BRCA2 are incredibly sensitive to PARP
inhibitor treatment.
But importantly, wild type cells are very resistant to that.
And in fact, even cells that have a single functional copy
of BRCA2 are very resistant. Now, that's important because
BRCA1 or BRCA2 mutations
can be inherited. And in those patients that have a very high risk of cancer, if
they have a BRCA mutation that's been inherited, they will have a single
functional copy in all of their normal cells in the body, and only the tumor will
have lost that second copy and therefore demonstrate a
sensitivity. So the potential for a large therapeutic window was really
important.
And so at the time,
the mechanism that we were thinking about was that inhibitors like
olaparib could prevent PARP from repairing those single-strand breaks.
Then when those single-strand breaks were encountered by a replication fork, you
would end up getting a one-ended DNA double-strand break.
In normal cells, that would be repaired by homologous recombination.
But in HR deficient cells or HRD cancer cells, such as BRCA
mutated cancers, they would end up having to use error-prone pathways like
NHEJ, and that would drive genomic instability and ultimately cancer specific cell
death.
And in fact, the phase one expansion cohort for
olaparib
went on to test that hypothesis in the clinic.
And what I'm showing is the very first patient who responded to olaparib
single agent. It was an ovarian cancer patient.
You can see the peritoneal mass reduces over a number of months.
And it was quite unusual for a phase one trial to be published in The New England
Journal of Medicine. But the reason for that is that this was the very first
example of synthetic lethality demonstrated in the clinic.
And olaparib went on to be approved in multiple different
tumor types and lines of therapy. But this is just to show you an example in
the first-line ovarian cancer
patients who've been treated with carboplatin
paclitaxel, then olaparib maintenance or placebo.
And you can see that that PARP inhibitor treatment has made a massive
difference in terms of progression-free survival.
And there are now four
first-generation PARP inhibitors with global approval.
So niraparib, rucaparib, and talazoparib, as well as olaparib in five tumor
types as shown here.
So although I think we can be really proud of the
science that went into this and ultimately those
treatments for patients, there are still key questions to be addressed for
PARP inhibitor synthetic lethality.
So for example, why don't
PARP inhibitors work in all tumors with HR deficiency?
Why doesn't the PARP knockout reproduce the PARP inhibitor synthetic lethality
in HRD cells? And why do different PARP inhibitors
demonstrate different levels of monotherapy activity?
So what I'd like to do for the rest of the talk is highlight some of the insights
we've gained
in addressing those questions and how that may help as we go forward to think about
other synthetic lethal approaches
in trying to generate new treatments for cancer.
So this is an analysis of
multiple different CRISPR screens that was carried out by Joseph Formant and his
team at AstraZeneca. And essentially what they identified was
PARP inhibitor sensitizer genes.
And that obviously includes what you would expect, HR genes such as
BRCA1, BRCA2, PALB2, and the RAD51 paralogs.
It also included DDR genes not directly involved in
HRAnd it also involved
other genes involved in different aspects of biology that could impact on HR
repair, such as the chromatin cohesion genes.
So these argue that the activity of PARP inhibitors could go beyond
HR deficiency.
But the question was really, do all deficiencies give similar levels of PARP
inhibitor sensitivity? And the answer to that is no.
And in fact, even within BRCA genes themselves, different
mutations can give you different outcomes to PARP inhibitor treatment.
So you can see here a wild-type BRCA cell.
This is in Jos Jonkers'
genetically engineered knockout mouse, where we've put back either a wild
type or a deleted version of BRCA1 or a
C61G mutant,
which is a ring domain mutation that still means that BRCA has
retained some of that activity.
And what you can see is that the deleted version is giving you long-term
responses in those animals.
But interestingly, the C61G mutation, which is a hypomorph, is
not as effective. And what we believe is that you have some residual
activity of BRCA,
which can modify the PARP response.
But also,
you will either have
a lack of an ability to get certain types of reversion mutations or,
in this case, maybe it's more easy to get those reversion
mutations. So we've gone on to look at
lots of different players within homologous recombination.
It's a very complex pathway,
and it's very difficult to just look at different cell lines which might have one
deficiency. It's really important to try and do isogenic analysis to try and tease
out relative levels of sensitivity.
It's also interesting that a single cell line is not going to be possible to
knock out every HR gene. So for example, in the
DU145 cell line, we can knock out BRCA1, but we couldn't knock
out BRCA2. It wasn't viable, and vice versa for SKOV3.
But together, what Joseph and the team were able to do is essentially
identify those
HR genes with the highest level of PARP inhibitor sensitivity, BRCA1, BRCA2,
PALB2, XLCC3, and RAD51C. Whereas others, such as
RAD51B and RAD54L, for example, are not giving you the same level of
sensitivity. An ATM deficiency is giving you some sort of intermediate level of
sensitivity.
But ultimately, what we really want to try and do is understand functionality
of HR pathway status. And so RAD51
foci will form during repair, so you can monitor those at
the basal level, and that will look something like this.
So these are the data from Violeta Serra when she was at Vall d'Hebron in
Barcelona. And essentially, she used RAD51
foci to look at the correlation with PARP inhibitor sensitivity.
So this is probably one of the largest patient-derived expand model cohorts
to be studied for PARP inhibitor response.
And you can see that all of those
tumors that showed regression had some form of HR
alteration, and they also had
very low levels of RAD51 foci.
You can see in those tumors that did not respond
that they might have had an alteration, but actually RAD51 foci is
being expressed here. We can see that RAD51 foci expression
indicating that there's likely to have been a reactivation of the pathway.
And in fact, that's what we're seeing when you start to analyze
the mechanisms behind that resistance.
And so more than 90% of PARP inhibitor-resistant models,
essentially, depending on or independently of their mechanism, will actually
reactivate HR function, and you'll see RAD51 foci.
So I think these data really show that PARP inhibitor response is linked to HRD,
but there can be a variability of response and that different levels of innate
sensitivity can modify that response, as can the likelihood of
acquired resistance.
And the second question, why
doesn't PARP knockout reproduce the PARP inhibitor
HRD synthetic lethality? Very early on, we'd identified a sort of
anomaly, if you like, which was we'd identified synthetic lethality with the
inhibitor. But when we looked at a
cell line
sort of cohort of just under 100 cell lines, what we saw when we were looking at
PARP inhibitor sensitivity was that those cells that had higher levels
of PARP protein expression could either be sensitive to
olaparib,
so low GI50s, or they could be insensitive.
But those cancer cell lines that had low levels of PARP1
invariably were not sensitive.
So this argued that you did need the protein to be present to get the sensitivity.
And really it was the work of Yves Pommier's group in 2012 that
also cemented that and showed that PARP inhibitors can
actually increase the trapping of PARP1 on chromatin.
And so now we have a modification of the mechanism whereby PARP trapping
essentially is important. And if PARP is still trapped
on the DNA when the replication fork reaches it, you end up
ultimately getting a DNA double-strand break, and then you again have the
scenario of HRD versus normal cell repair.
So there have been some questions about the importance of PARP trapping even as
recently as a couple of years ago.
I think the clinical data seem to be consistent with that in the sense that
rucaparib, which is a poor trapper, was not shown to have monotherapy activity in a
clinic. Talazoparib and olaparib,
niraparib, and rucaparib all had sort of PARP trapping capability and showed
monotherapy activity. But really, I think it was only very
recently where we published this paper in NAR that we were able to
find a PARP1 mutation that provided separation of
function between polyrelation inhibition observations and PARP
trapping. So if you look at sarucaparib, which is one of the PARP1
selective agents,
it's a much stronger trapper than olaparib.
And what you see interestingly is that that PARP
trappingDNA damage, genomic instability, and cell kill are
all sort of linked, and in BRCA2-deficient cells, they're higher.
So you can see a greater sensitivity in a BRCA2
isogenic knockout. You can see greater levels of PARP trapping, and that
correlates with greater levels of double-strand break formation based on
γH2AX and on genomic instability based on
micronuclei.
And in two independent clones in a sort of
experiment where we were trying to generate resistance, what we found was
that two resistant clones also then had lost
the ability for SERPs to trap.
And that mutation, L77P, is in the helical domain of
PARP1, which is involved in stabilizing DNA binding.
So this was some really nice evidence that resistance could
be correlated with a loss of trapping.
But I think what was even more convincing is it has the opposite effect on
veliparib. So veliparib is normally not a very potent
cell killer of BRCA-deficient cells.
But what you can see is in that PARP1 mutation setting,
you've increased the efficacy of veliparib
in this model, and you can see that correlating with that, you see greater levels
of trapping. And you're not seeing actually greater levels of
polyolation inhibition. If anything, it's slightly worse.
So this is the first time we've separated polyolation
inhibition from trapping. So I think these data, at least
as far as we're concerned, really provides
strong indication that trapping is really important for monotherapy activity.
So why do PARP inhibitors demonstrate
different levels of monotherapy activity? Because that's certainly been seen.
If we look at the long-term
survival of ovarian cancer patients in first line,
olaparib has a ratio of less than one, but rucaparib and niraparib
has a ratio of greater than one.
And so what's the basis behind that if we want to learn, for
example, about the next generation PARP inhibitors and how we might improve them?
So one of the things that we observed is that there's a very steep cutoff
between
PARP inhibitor dose and tumor regression.
So in this experiment in a XenTech HBCX10 model, what you
can see is that 25 mg per kg of olaparib can't get the tumor under control,
but the 50 mg per kg and the 100 mg per kg can.
So these are the averages of 10 independent tumors.
If you look at polyolation inhibition, what you see is that all of, and it's very
hard to see because it just goes straight down initially, but
essentially all of the doses will completely inhibit PARP.
So you basically have polyolation inhibition in all of the cases, and it's about
really the recovery of that polyolation and therefore PARP
activity that seems to be important.
And you can see that you get faster recovery with the lower doses.
And if we look at the time above the IC50, IC90,
IC95, so the closer you get to 100% inhibition and the time over that,
you see the biggest differences between an active dose at 50 mg and an inactive
dose effectively at 25 mg. So you can see that here.
So the trend is towards complete inhibition of PARP correlating
with tumor shrinkage and efficacy.
And a very talented
modeler,
James Yates, when he was at AstraZeneca, came up with this
mathematical model looking at the relationship between polyolation
inhibition and the number of predicted single-strand breaks.
And what he saw was this, a biphasic scenario where really only when you get past
90% to 95% inhibition, do you see this big increase in predicted breaks.
And for many years, we weren't able to really demonstrate that
directly
in the lab until we were able to utilize
IntoDNA's STRIDE technology, which quantifies
either single-strand breaks or double-strand breaks.
And what you can see essentially is that same biphasic relationship that we were
able to demonstrate
and that we'd seen in the mathematical model.
So that argues you've got to try and get almost complete inhibition
of PARP.
What does it mean in terms of duration of treatment scheduling?
Well, these experiments, long-term experiments in the same HBCX10 model,
show that if you give
olaparib at the clinical equivalent dose of 100 mg per kg
daily
for 100 days, you don't get any tumors
escaping on treatment. But if you halve that dose or you give that
same high dose intermittently, what you see is that you're now getting tumors
escaping on treatment, and that correlated with a greater residual
tumor volume. So in those scenarios, you had nearly 10%
residual tumor versus only 1.5% for the high
continuous dosing. So what we think this means is that you're more likely to have
tumor cells that can become resistant.
What we know about resistance reactivation of HRR, that will also
impact on subsequent treatments such as platinum treatment
or topoisomerase treatment in the clinic.
So we've looked at the different first-generation PARP
inhibitors to try and understand what it is that might drive that long-term
efficacy. And really what we've seen is obviously differences
in trapping that I mentioned. Importantly, differences in the
primary pharmacology that lead to different windows between HRD
and HR proficiency. So rucaparib and olaparib have
wide windows. Niraparib, talazoparib, more narrow windows.
You can see talazoparib is shifted to the left because it's very potent in terms
of cytotoxicity.
But also secondary pharmacology is quite different.
So talazoparib and olaparib have clean
secondary pharmacologies. Niraparib and rucaparib hit quite a lot of other
things that can lead to
the side effects that are specific for those agents.
So hypertension, increased liver enzymes, insomnia, and so on.
And if we look at the safety profiles in the Phase III trials,
Grade 3 or 4, what you can see is that that is different between the different
PARP inhibitors. And the important bit that I want us to focus on really is the
higherNow, percentage of patients that had to have dose reductions
as interruptions. So if we think back to the preclinical models, what it's telling
us is you don't want to have that. You want to give high doses continuously if you
can. If tolerability interferes with that, then that is going to potentially impact
on the long-term patient outcome.
So I'm going to summarize now what we've learned.
So first of all,
DDR represents a good opportunity for synthetic lethality based cancer therapies
due to loss of function and the resulting targetable dependencies.
Just a word of caution, not all synthetic lethal opportunities will be detected by
gene knockout in a deficient background, and we should be doing
inhibitor screens as well to try and identify examples where
that might give you the synthetic lethality.
And that target identification is only the first step really.
Success is going to require a synthetic lethal target with a potential wide
therapeutic index, inhibitors with clean pharmacology, specificity and
potency, and an understanding of the level of target engagement that's required.
Degraders, for example, may need to give close to knockout levels.
We had a DNPH1 scenario where the knockout had been published
to give part of the sensitivity. We used inhibitors and PROTACs.
With the PROTACs, we were nearly getting 95% or more
inhibition of protein expression.
But we still couldn't phenocopy the knockout.
And then finally, an understanding of the quality and quality tools for effective
patient selection is going to be important, and I think you'll hear more about that
from Tim. So,
I'd just like to thank my ESAC colleagues and all of our collaborators in the past
for their work that's contributed to this talk today. Thank you.
Thanks very much, Mark. Fantastic talk as always.
There are plenty of seats in front, actually, so please come and
fill up all the seats there.
It's great to see a
really packed room here, really does show the interest in synthetic lethality.
Just looking at all of the old photographs from Mark and Graham
Smith and Steve Jackson,
it did bring back memories because I think the first time I met Mark was when
I was still at the Royal Marsden, and Mark was still at Kudos, and we were
preparing slides for ASCO.
I shouldn't say ASCO at this meeting, but yeah.
This was back in 2006, 2007 time. But
that's 20 years ago, Mark. That's a whole lifetime. Wow.
And we don't look any older, do we?
We actually look exactly the same.
So, yeah. Anyway. All right. So you've already
heard about the
evolution of PARP inhibitors and how we've
been changing and how we think about
PARP inhibitor development, and
I want to really discuss and highlight the
progress that we have made, but really the pitfalls that we
have seen and have
encountered in the clinic ultimately, but also to really show some promise as
well and how we can move things forward ultimately in the
clinic. So these are my disclosures.
Many friends, many of you in this room, I think.
All right. So for me as a clinician,
really thinking about how we can raise that bar for all of our
patients
in the clinic. It's really about going beyond the usual
suspects in terms of drugging the
cancer lesions that we can truly go after.
And I really do think that exploiting synthetic
lethality will help us do that.
And I say that because the focus of precision oncology for the
past 20-odd years has really been on the gain-of-function
alterations. The targetable ones like EGFR
mutations in lung cancer, HER2 amplification in
breast cancer, and that's great, and that's fantastic.
But I really do think that to really raise that bar and to go
beyond the usual suspects, we really need to go after the
untapped space here. Right? And I do think that that comprises
gain-of-function alterations like CCNE1
overexpression or amplification.
We have no approved drugs right now for patients with those
alterations. And also thinking beyond BRCA1
and BRCA2 mutations as well. Are there other
tumor suppressor alterations that we can go after, right?
And so I really do think that there is an untapped 71%
space that
remains to be drugged. And
we are seeing some success, and I've laid out a few of these
right now in synthetic lethality.
What I consider hot areas,
what I consider emerging areas, and what I consider novel areas.
So hot areas I've put in there what Mark's already alluded to,
POP1 selective inhibitors in HRR mutation
cancers.
Many of you are involved with the MTA corpus of PRMT5
inhibitors in MTAP loss tumors.
Tango, BMS, Amgen looking very
promising based on
Phase I/II data, and these drugs, I have no doubt,
are showing great promise and hopefully great success in Phase III
trials. And then also recently, the FDA
provided fast track designation to the ATR inhibitor
from Arteos in combination with low-dose irinotecan in
patients who have
ATM loss or negative cancers there, and that was
based on a 50% response rate seen in ATM
loss cancers across the board.
And then as an emerging area, what I want to focus on really is in
targeting CCNE1 aberrant tumors and share with you some
data from
the PKM1 study in combination with a Wee1
inhibitorThere are also other emerging paralogs, if you
like. So one helicase inhibitor in MSI tumors,
SMARCA2 inhibitors in SMARCA4 mutation tumors that you'll hear about from
Steve.
KIF18A inhibitors of patients are actually selected for
SEN tumors, for example, by undertaking whole genome doubling.
BAS inhibitors in EP300 mutation tumors, and also
again, what you will hear from Steve will be
the activity, or at least pre-clinically, and the potential
of ARID1B inhibitors in ARID1A mutation cancers.
So ultimately, I think,
we need to think about these synthetic lethal strategies.
And as you know, as Mark has already alluded to, this has really been
led by many different DDR inhibitor
approaches that I've listed here.
And as you know, it's been really facilitated through
the discovery of novel precision targets enabled
by modern CRISPR technologies and
also progress that have been made
in cancer genome sequencing technologies.
And so that's really allowed physicians like myself to use
biomarker-driven patient selection strategies to guide the clinical
development and also to think about rational combinations.
And the whole DDR landscape has expanded beyond PARP
inhibitors, ATR, WEN helicase, Pol theta, the list goes
on and on. And there are other agents as well in pre-clinical
testing.
And some of you may have already seen this slide that I've shown in the past, but
here's a change here, because I really do want to share some hard truths, that
there has been a recent fine-tuning of some
DDR inhibitors as listed here. Several agents
have been deprioritized by big pharma, by biotech companies,
including the WEE1 inhibitor from AstraZeneca,
dovrasirsob,
DNA PK inhibitor,
papirasirsob, and AZD-7648, the
USP1 inhibitor,
ATR inhibitors, and ATM inhibitors. Right?
And so I think we need to take a step back, and I think we need to
think about
what are the lessons
learned from all of these different experiences that we've had in the
clinic. And for me, just looking back at the
past 20 years and the development of all of these different
agents, I think I can summarize the three key
considerations for the optimal development of
synthetic lethality strategies in the clinic.
And some of you may think, "Oh, this is obvious," but I think it's important that
we get down into the weeds of dealing with these three key
challenges. Number one, the therapeutic index; number two,
really developing a robust predictive biomarker strategy;
and number three, to think about rational combinations that are also
well-tolerated as well. So here are the three key considerations.
Let's start off with therapeutic index.
So
all of you will know with these DDR drugs like PARP
inhibitors, there are three really main mechanism-based toxicities.
Mild suppression, not like chemo, but we do
see some falls in the different lineages
depending on the actual drug, as Mark already alluded to.
We do see nausea, vomiting, and diarrhea.
Again, not like chemotherapy, but it is something that we have to
control. And also fatigue, usually mild, grade one to two
fatigue. But I think it's really important to point out that there are key
differences in the types and grades of toxicities between the different
DDR drugs. Right? If you were to blindfold me and give me a taste test
with the different DDR drugs, I could tell you if it
was just mainly ANC drops
and neutrophils. That's what we see with CHEK1 inhibitors, typically,
like praxasertib.
With ATR inhibitors, typically as a mechanism-based tox, we do see some
anemia as the main mechanism-based toxicities.
There are also differences in the types and grades of these
toxicities between the different agents, but within
each DDR class. So ultimately, the different PARP
inhibitors, as Mark alluded to, have different types and grades of
toxicities.
In addition to that, some drugs do have off-target toxicities, like
QT prolongation,
elevations in LFTs. That was something we did see with rucaparib.
And ultimately, the issue here is that these toxicities do impact
the dosing in the clinic. They lead to drug holes, drug
reductions,
and ultimately potentially impact the monotherapy activity
in the clinic. And the evidence for that pre-clinically is what
Mark's already published on by Jemal Latel, and
that will ultimately also have an impact
on combinations, especially if there are overlapping
toxicities. So what I would say, if there's just one point to take
home, and that is really to judge each DDR agent
individually based on the pharmacology pre-clinically,
based on kinase screens, based on the
on-target versus off-target effects, but also the clinical data.
And don't judge them as a class, because each drug is
extremely different from the other.
So what can we do about these toxicities?
I've laid out here the obvious things like the clinical measures,
supportive measures like managing GI toxicities
with anti-diarrheals, with anti-nausea pills,
to think about dose modifications such as drug holidays
or to really drop the dose. Right? But we of course try and avoid that.
Maybe we should be avoiding the whole concomitant dosing piece and
reallyThink about giving drugs in a maintenance setting if they're
DDR agents, and that has led to success with olaparib
in frontline ovarian cancer, and
also pancreatic cancer. But I think more excitingly, there are
improvements that are being conducted now and being done in terms of the
drug pharmacology. Mark alluded to the PARP1 selective
agents like sarubrutinib or pelacapronib or other agents such as
from Duke-Street Bio,
and several others. And there are some posters being shown at this
ACR meeting as well that I would urge you to visit as well.
And ultimately, the whole thinking behind this is that we can drive
greater bang for your buck, if you like, to drive greater PK
exposures with much, much less toxicity, and
therefore really maintain high PK exposures of the drug
that greater than 95% correlation inhibition, and
really maintain that over time without any dose
reductions, because it is something that we do see with the
first-generation PARP inhibitors, which are all
PARP1/2 inhibitors.
There's a company called Sumitomo that have
developed a liposomally encapsulated CHEK1 inhibitor to try
and minimize the impact on the bone marrow.
And with this, the thinking here is to increase tumor exposures and to really
minimize normal tissue toxicities and to minimize
the neutropenia that we do see with these drugs.
With WEE1 inhibitors, these are being fine-tuned to dial out
PLK1 and 2 inhibition. Examples of that are the drug
from Dabio, which I'll touch on later in my slide deck.
It's at Arestip, and also from Apria,
APR-1051.
As a clinician, I think we need to be a little bit more creative.
I think gone are the days where we can just come in and combine drugs A
plus B, and this is not just PARP inhibitors I'm talking about.
This is
with all classes of drugs. We need to think about
schedules and dosing that's really focused on the biology and focused
on preclinical modeling. And many of you in the audience can help us
clinicians with that to think about alternating doses,
intermittent dosing, if that's going to be the optimal schedule
for that particular class of agents in combination, to think
about gap scheduling for the optimal normal tissue
recovery
if there is overlapping toxicity.
And if there is indeed a problem with toxicity, maybe use that to
its greatest advantage. So there are now dual payload
ADCs using
exatecan payload plus an ATR inhibitor.
There are drugs from Callio Therapeutics, there are drugs from Cross
Bridge as well with HER2 targeting agents
and
TROP2 targeting ADCs respectively.
And these are currently in pre-clinical or in early
clinical development.
So
there are
other considerations as well. Number two, as I mentioned,
is really thinking about the predictive biomarker strategy.
And I say that because I get referred many
patients with these alterations, and I'll be honest, everyone
thinks that
any patient with a DDR mutation will respond to
a PARP inhibitor. And that is not true.
That is absolutely not true, and Mark has already shown some preclinical
data suggesting that really there is a tiered system.
Again, this is totally unpublished, totally my own opinion.
So I can see all the cameras going up when I said that.
That's funny.
But for me, tier one would be BRCA2 right at the top.
BRCA2 deletions, and then BRCA1, PALB2, RAD51C and
D as tier one alterations. And then at
bottom, bottom of the heap are really the ATM
CHEK1, CHEK2, RAD54L that Mark mentioned
earlier, and FANCL as well. And to me, these do not
sensitize to PARP inhibitors because I don't think
they really lead to an HRD phenotype in these cancers.
So I think we need to be a little bit more thoughtful as to how we match
patients
with PARP inhibitors and other DDR agents as well because it does give us a bad
reputation.
But ultimately, as we're thinking long term, we really
need functional HRD assays. We do have
some approved HRD assays, but I think these are flawed.
These are based on genomic scarring, and I'll come to why these are
not the optimal functional assay in my coming slides.
Number two, we need to remember, and this is stating the obvious, but all DDR
agents have different mechanisms of action.
So the truth is we need different predictive biomarkers of sensitivity
for true synthetic lethality in a clinic.
However, all trials use the same 15
HRR mutations to select patients, and that means we're
going back to all of these 15 alterations.
And so if you enroll a patient with a tier two or three alteration,
that's going to lower your chance of seeing a response, for example, to a PARP
inhibitor.
But ultimately, we need to think about the actual individual drugs as
we think about the mechanisms. And so for me, under homologous
recombination deficiency or HRD, that's where I would place your PARP
inhibitors.
But I would place the WEE1, the CHEK1, and ATR inhibitors probably
under replication stress. So really different
mechanisms to think about there. And then as you think about HRD, to
really focus on the tier one HRR mutations and to
also consider thinking about looking at these new
functional HRD assays as well,
one of which Mark already mentioned.
And thenSo when you think about WEE1, CHEK1, and ATR
inhibitors, really it's not about HRD anymore, but it's about replication
stress. And thinking about replication stress, the problem is that right
now we don't have a clear certified replication stress
assay, right? So we can't select patients prospectively for
these trials, and so we're really reliant on
replication stress surrogates. And these include CCNE1
amplification or cyclin E IHC loss, so expression.
Actually, that should be overexpression. I apologize.
And then FBXW7 mutations, which do lead to cyclin E
overexpression, PPP2RNA mutations,
ATM mutations, and ATM IHC loss. And
also, to be honest, there are some tumors like USC, so uterine
serous carcinoma, very rare but very aggressive endometrial
cancer.
These are cancers that have inherently very high replication
stress. So for those tumors, you probably don't need to even select
prospectively molecularly for replication stress.
But again, I do think we need functional assays
to think about how we can match patients with their drugs.
And so
I often get asked,
with the portfolio that we have at MD Anderson, how do we
match patients with the different drugs?
So again, unpublished, okay?
My own opinion, but when I see someone with a DDR mutation and they're a
trial candidate,
if they have one of these tier one alterations, I would offer them a PARP-1
selective PARP inhibitor. If they have a co-mutation that makes sense and
I have a combination, I would be guided by the co-mutation and
combine it with a PARP-1 selective inhibitor.
For example, by giving them a PI3K inhibitor in combination with a
PARP inhibitor. But if they have an ATM mutation or ATM
IHC loss, I would not offer them a PARP inhibitor.
Instead, I would offer them an ATR inhibitor or a different
DDR agent. But the real challenge that we have in the clinic is
this blue bit here. The real challenge is in the
post-PARP inhibitor DDR mutation setting.
We're now testing novel agents like POL theta inhibitors,
USP1 inhibitors, Park inhibitors, so on and so forth.
The list goes on and on. And of course,
all of these drugs in combination as well.
But I do think thinking about the different alterations,
these alterations here should be considered in their own category,
where we think about not just WEE1, not just PKM1, but also CDK2
inhibitors, and also the now emerging cyclin E
inhibitors and degraders moving into the clinic as well.
Ultimately, for me, what's important and what we do in our clinic at MD Anderson is
to really track patients longitudinally with tumor
monitoring, so repeat biopsies and also blood monitoring, looking at
ctDNA to really try and match patients with the tumor biology
with the right drugs in real time. And what I would love
to do now is to really shift this entire journey to the left to
think about prevention, to think about screening, interception strategies,
to think about the use of PARP-1 selective agents, perhaps in a prevention setting
as well to treat high-risk individuals.
So
I just want to now focus in my last
few minutes on
these cancers with these alterations that I mentioned, the CCNE1,
FBXW7, PPP2RNA mutations. You can see it's not
uncommon.
I would argue that it's seen in about 30%, 40% of ovarian
cancer. And how about all of these other cancers? Right.
I'm not going to go through the details now because of time, but
all of these cancers with these alterations represent key
areas of unmet clinical need. We don't have specific
approved options for all of those patients.
So I'm going to share some clinical data to show the
activity and how that's actually made us evolve
the
biomarker plan as well. So we conducted an
investigator-initiated trial at MD Anderson led by my colleague Sicheng Fu
in our department at MD Anderson using the AstraZeneca
WEE1 inhibitor.
And this is an all-comer population.
And you can see here an ORR of 27% only
in CCNE1-amplified solid tumor patients.
But when you actually then isolate that to just the ovarian cancer patients, the
ORR goes up to about 36%.
So how about cyclin E1 IHC overexpression?
And there was a study called the IGNITE study
whereby they had a cohort of patients with cyclin E1
overexpression by IHC, but in patients who are
not CCNE1 amplified. And you can see again pretty high
impressive 43% overall response when you
consider both radiological and GCA 1 to
5 responses. So you do see perhaps a higher
response rate and patient benefit when you think about
IHC overexpression. So how about the
functional assays that I mentioned earlier?
And we know that again
the challenges that we have is that the current assays that are approved,
the HRD assays, are all based on static genomic signatures
that really reflect historical DNA damage and not
real-time biology. These are genomic scarring assays, and the name
gives you the answer there is that these are scars that are permanent.
And so really the other assays that have been looked at are
RAD51 foci assays. They tell us about the protein presence, but
there really isn't a clear relation to functional activity.
And so there is an assay from IntoDNA called the
STRIDE assay. There's one for HRD that looks at the
functional engagement. And importantly here, the signal's only
generated when RAD51 is actually physically loaded
onto the DNA double-strand break.Srandas.
And then they also have a replication stress assay that looks at the
act of response and the temporal dynamics of the
replication stress response.
And there's some data here, very early, but it does
show the differences that you can see between the patients who
benefit versus those who don't. And in terms of replication stress,
again, you can see the visualization of the progression of how
the actual tumor responds
to replication stress.
So finally, just to end, because I'm way beyond my time now,
just very quickly, and we presented some data from the
PKMη1 study in combination
with the WEE1 inhibitor. So PKMη1,
the whole thinking behind this was based on data from Dan
DeRoche's lab showing that loss of PKMη1 is
synthetically lethal with cyclin E overexpressed
cells, and the highest-scoring druggable hit was PKMη1,
and that led to lanresortib that was developed by Repare Therapeutics.
They then did a chemogenomic screen and found that actually
PPP2R1A and FBXW7 mutations actually
sensitize as well to PKMη1 inhibition.
The challenge there was that with lanresortib, the drug from
Repare, we only observed TGI in the lab, and in the
clinic, there was only modest clinical activity with
monotherapy, and that really led to combinations, for
example, with the ATR inhibitor, kemensertib, but also
WEE1 was identified as a top synthetic lethal hit in
PKMη1
chemogenomic screens. And so that provided a rationale to combine
with setrestib, the WEE1 inhibitor from Dabio, plus
PKMη1 lanresortib.
And the whole mechanistic thinking behind this is that WEE1
inhibition exacerbates CCNE1 amplification-induced
replication stress during S-phase, and at the G2M
checkpoint, the combination really reduces
CDK1 phosphorylation, leading to its hyperactivation,
and cells carrying unrepaired DNA damage are driven prematurely
into mitosis, mitotic catastrophe, and cell death.
And so nice synergy and regression
seen across the board, and these different alterations and different
tumor types. It was well-tolerated, and in the trial, it was
mainly Grade 1 to 2 toxicity. So that therapeutic index was
there.
I'll show the PD data here showing induction of gamma-H2AX
and also both threonine 14 and tyrosine 15 reductions
showing target inhibition from both drugs.
Here's a waterfall plot in all patients, but what is of interest is
really the durability, but also the activity in ovarian cancer
patients, overall response rate at the MTD dose of
50%. And again, when you look at the CCNE1 amplified ovarian
cancer patients, that overall response does go up, although in
small numbers of patients. And here's a patient who had a nice
response. I'm just going to jump through this.
CDDNA responses supporting the data. And that's it.
So strategies for optimizing synthetic lethal strategies.
I think I've gone through this already, and that's it.
I'd like to acknowledge all of my colleagues at MD Anderson,
and many collaborators, many of you are in this room.
So thank you very much, everyone.
All right. Without further ado, over to you, Steve.
So Steve Ballen, the CSO from FogHorn. Thank you very much.
Great. Thanks. First, thanks very much to Dr.
Yap for giving me the opportunity to represent
the work going on at FogHorn Therapeutics.
So I work at FogHorn, and I am a stockholder of FogHorn.
So at FogHorn, we've been focused really since the inception of the company
on drugging chromatin biology. And the basic
principle here is quite simple in that the structure of
chromatin dictates its function.
So chromatin that's open, as you can see here with
the green segment of DNA, can result
in gene expression, whereas chromatin DNA that's tightly
wound
doesn't result in gene expression.
And so from the inception, we've been focused on the machines really
that control the structure of chromatin.
The BAF complex or SWI/SNF was our focus of
attention from the onset of the company, and since then, we've expanded
into other important machines such as the CBP and
EP300 paralogs.
But I'm going to focus my talk now on the BAF complex,
specifically ARID1A and ARID1B, the
paralogs that have no enzymatic activity,
and then also towards the end of the talk, I'll show some
new preclinical data
for SMARCA2 which
is related to the paralog SMARCA4.
So looking in context at the targets that we work on,
you can see ARID1A, CBP, EP300, and SMARCA4 on this chart.
These are some of the most mutated targets in
oncology, and thus our interest.
So to start with ARID1B, the strategy here is
to selectively drug ARID1B to
address the very large mutant population of
ARID1A. ARID1A is one of the most mutated
targets in
cancer, and certainly the most mutated subunit in the BAF
complex.And so the
idea here is classic synthetic lethality, that cancer cells that have had
to delete ARID1A in order to survive become
dependent on ARID1B. Healthy cells that have both
copies
can rely on their 1A copy if we selectively drug
1B, and this is illustrated quite nicely on the right-hand side of the slide,
where we have an effect of knocking down ARID1B only
in the ARID1A null lines. No effect in the
wild-type lines shown on the left there,
illustrating how we would expect to obtain a therapeutic index by
selectively targeting 1B.
The challenge, however, is how exactly to do
that.
ARID1B, I have to say, is probably one of the most challenging
targets that I've worked on in my career, and the reasons for that
are numerous.
ARID1B is not an enzyme, making drugging challenging.
It's very similar to the paralog ARID1A, making
selectivity very challenging, and half of the
polypeptide is disordered, making drugging
even that much more challenging.
And so this really played nicely to the platform that we've been
building since the inception of the company.
The ability to screen and characterize these
multi-subunit complexes, like the BAF complex, really
allowed us to get after drugging ARID1B.
And to do that,
we've screened
many, many different collections with many different methodologies
over the years. And
in the early days, despite having
biophysics in place to validate the hits, we were fooled
and spent more months than I would care to admit
chasing molecules that end up not being real,
various aggregators and promiscuous molecules.
So only after quite a bit of effort,
we obtained genuine biophysically validated chemical
matter, and I'm showing two examples here. I'm calling them Series A and Series B.
You can see that for Series A, I've put a green
rectangle around the selective chemical matter that came from this
particular screen,
and then I'm showing some ITC data for a representative from
Series B also that's nice and
selective.
And
the reasons we focused extensively on obtaining
selective chemical matter from the start,
we didn't want to have to be engineering selectivity in
at the level of degradation. We wanted the selectivity baked into the
selective binders
to ARID1B such that then when we converted these into
protein degraders, that the selectivity would be baked in, and we could
worry about optimizing other properties along the way to
a drug. And that strategy, I think, has served us well thus far.
So here's a bit of a representation of the progression
of an early hit. This is from the first series.
We were structurally enabled, so that was quite an advantage in
optimizing this chemical matter.
But we were able to, in a reasonable amount of time,
progress a weak hit at 100 micromolar on the left to
nanomolar
hits on the right-hand side. And these then were used as starting
points for generating heterobifunctional degraders.
I should add that it's always been my hope that these
selective binders, if they achieve a certain threshold of
potency, could have
function in and of themselves and obviate the need to
convert them into heterobifunctional degraders, and we keep
looking for that. We haven't seen that yet, but I think as our molecules get
more and more potent,
I
hold out hope that eventually we will find binders that have function in and of
themselves.
So here I'm showing the progression of two different approaches that we've
pushed in parallel. We've used both VHL and
cereblon ligases in order to convert our selective
binders into degraders.
And the reason we've advanced both in parallel is we wanted as much
optionality as possible with the chemical matter that we're
advancing forward. You can see that our cereblon approach
is about tenfold more potent than VHL, but
both of these remain of interest, and the data that I'll show you
in the subsequent slides, some of that's for VHL, and some of that's from cereblon,
and I'll try and be clear to point out what's what going forward.
But definitely excited by the progression of the
cereblon series and the potential that that holds for oral
delivery of the eventual drugs.
So looking a little more deeply at a representative from both VHL
and cereblon series, we see a nice effect in the
westerns here. We see a little bit of a hook effect with this particular
cereblon-based molecule.
And on the right-hand side, I point out the kinetics of these
two representative molecules. We put a high premium on
understanding the rate of degradation of all of our
degrader molecules, and this program is no exception.
Looking then at the mechanism of degradation.
Here I'm showing the VHL example, but the same data
hold for cereblon,
namely that we are on target for degradation with the
proteasome, as you can see from the data on the right-hand side
here.And then focusing
more specifically on the cereblon-based degraders, we've
profiled some off-target neo-substrates, and we
were particularly gratified to see that we don't have
any off-target neo-substrate activity with our
cereblon-based degraders.
Then looking more broadly at the selectivity for both the VHL
and the cereblon-based series, you can see that we have quite a nice
separation between ARID1B and the rest of the volcano.
In this case, we see no degradation of ARID1A, and that's the case
here on the right with cereblon as well.
I think it's clear from these two proteomics graphs that
the selectivity we see from our cereblon series is already a little bit superior
to what we see from VHL, and that's consistent with the superior
potency that we see from cereblon as well.
But extremely gratified that looking at the cereblon-based
degrader here, ARID1B is the top
hit across the entire proteome, and we don't see any effect
whatsoever on ARID1A. So our original strategy of
engineering the selectivity at the level of binder has worked quite nicely
as we've made heterobifunctional degraders, and we basically don't
worry about hitting the ARID1A paralog as we
advance these series forward.
So then,
moving on to better characterize the ternary complex formed
with our different degraders. As we all know, the ternary complex is the
important complex that drives degradation.
So we've put quite a bit of effort into understanding the ternary
complex
formation for both VHL and cereblon-based degraders.
This data here is from our VHL-based
series, and you can see here that with the red arrow, we form a ternary
complex with our heterobifunctional molecule at exactly the
weight that one would predict
based on the sum of all the individual components.
So really thrilled to see a native mass spec demonstration of the
formation of a ternary complex here.
And then we further characterized this ternary complex by making point
mutations in the ARID1B binding site as well as
in the ligase
itself. And you can see that each of those individual point
mutations results in only binary complexes, as one would
expect, whereas only in the native system here do we
observe the full ternary complex form.
So I think we have a pretty nice characterization of
the ternary complex.
This enabled us to then proceed and determine crystal
structures of these ternary complexes.
What I'm showing here is for VHL.
And I want to compare two things
in the next two slides. One is the binary complex, that is the
heterobifunctional binding the ARID1B target,
and I want to compare that with the ternary complex that's
formed.
And that's illustrated with these
arrows here, and I've peeled away the VHL protein just for sake of
clarity. But it was really interesting that the binder
sort of moves off with this trajectory down toward the lower
left-hand portion of the figure,
whereas what we observed in the ternary complex formation, and this came as a
complete surprise to us, that the small molecule actually
adopts a twist and moves off toward the upper
left-hand portion of the slide. And this was quite
eye-opening when we got this structure.
It explained quite a bit of the SAR that we didn't really understand at the
time, and it has given us a nice path forward to more
rationally advance our molecules forward.
Recently, we were able to obtain also the cereblon co-crystal
structure, and we were quite gratified to see that this twist
in the heterobifunctional molecule is roughly the
same for both VHL and cereblon-based degraders.
So these are
quite nicely structures that actually inform the chemistry and help
to point a path forward for the optimization of these molecules, which is
not always the case.
Furthering our understanding of ternary complex
formation, we've developed a FRET and NanoBRET assays
to characterize the ternary complex formation with a bit
higher throughput than crystallography on the left here.
And then on the right, I show both FRET and
SPR-based assays that
quantitate the degree of cooperativity upon ternary complex
formation. We can see here that in the cereblon
case, adding ARID to the binary complex to make the
ternary complex decreases the KD by
about tenfold, which is really exciting that we're able to see that
level of cooperativity in a quantitative way.
And then finally, for our ARID1B effort, we've
put quite a bit of effort into identifying
the target genes of ARID1B engagement.
We've identified both genes that move up and move down in the
presence of knocking down ARID1B.
We've then taken these validated target genes and
explored the effect of our selective degraders on these target
genes, and we're quite gratified to see.
First, on the left, we see a decrease of the ARID1B protein levels,
and this correlates very nicely with this gene in the middle here,
which is a gene that we've validated to be a down gene, and it moves down in a
nice dose-responsive manner. Also important to see that the ligase
dead version of the heterobifunctional has no effect on this gene.
So I think we're nicely on target.
And then we selected aA representative up
gene with the same molecule 654 that shows that
gene moving up when we dose our compound.
So I think we are on the right track with these efforts
and
look forward to updating you on our progress in the future.
I'm now going to shift and spend the remaining five minutes of my
time to talk about a more advanced program.
This is our selective SMARCA2 inhibitor
program. This is in collaboration with Lilly.
Really productive collaboration, I should add.
But the idea here is exactly the same as it is for
ARID11B. That is,
we are looking to drug the SMARCA4
mutations found in a number of different tumors by
selectively drugging SMARCA2.
Normal cells that have both wild type SMARCA2 and SMARCA4
copies can use their SMARCA4 copy to compensate,
opening up a therapeutic window, whereas cancer cells
shown on the right here,
they've deleted the tumor suppressor SMARCA4 in order to gain a growth
advantage,
but that leaves them susceptible to drugging of the paralog
SMARCA2, and then those cells die.
So this is the overall approach.
But one thing that's important to point out about these SMARCA4 or
BRG1 mutations, this represents about
10% of lung cancer.
But if you look at the Kaplan-Meier curve on the left, you see that the outcome
for patients that have these SMARCA4 or BRG1
mutations is quite poor. These are really
terrible for the prognosis of these patients.
And furthermore, these tumors have been characterized as
cold tumors,
whereas checkpoint approaches don't really work so well for these
patients. We've published in the
past on a humanized mouse study looking at the
combination between our molecule 909
and
PD-1 checkpoint inhibitors, and we saw very interesting
combination results that we disclosed last year.
And this year, I have new combination data to show you.
First,
I want to just show the profile of 909, which is
LY4050784. Again, this has been
advanced in collaboration with Lilly.
And so what the team at Lilly has shown, so
this is data from the Lilly team,
Anke Koppel and Xuan Cheng,
and their colleagues at Lilly. So here we
have a syngeneic model where we have knocked out
BRG1 to mimic the situation
in the
clinic.
And we've looked at the combination effect then between 909
and the murine version of an
anti-PD-1 antibody.
So first I'll point out here, this is the effect
of the PD-1 antibody shown here in brown,
not much of an effect in this
tumor situation.
But in combination between 909 and the
anti-PD-1, we see dramatic shrinkage of these tumors,
basically six out of six complete responses
in this study. And after we stop dosing, here
shown by the dotted line, we monitor these tumors for
about 70
additional days. We see no regrowth of these tumors.
And also excitingly, we see very nice tolerability
as judged by the body weights on the right-hand side there.
But perhaps even more exciting than the effect on
the tumors themselves is when we then tried to
rechallenge
the same mice that had been used in the previous study, and
we used as a control H-matched naive mice.
We see that on the opposite flank from where the tumor was implanted
in the previous study on the previous page, we see no ability for
these tumors to take
in these animals. So this seems like quite an exciting
demonstration of an immune memory effect,
and one that we are quite excited to continue to
understand
in combination with our SMARCA2 inhibitor
909.
So
I want to give a thank you to the whole Foghorn team for
generating the data that I've shown you now, and I want to give a big thank you
to Anki and Xuan, and Barry Taylor
at Lilly for generously allowing us to present this data that was
generated at Lilly. And thank you for your time.
Thank you very much, Steve. We have
until 11:45 for potential questions.
So you can either put your questions online
or please feel free to
go up to the mic
if you have any
questions.
I think I can start then.
Go for it, yeah.
Thank you. I'm Madhu from Sprint Bioscience, Sweden, Stockholm.
My question is about-That's great that BRCA mutations
has
really ruined nice PARP inhibitor, has ruined nice to clear
the BRCA mutations. But what about there are
several study shows that
RAD inhibitor or RAD51 inhibitor can make BRCA less
like nature.
Do you think that it can be also combined with the olaparib?
I think the beauty of synthetic lethality is that one part
of the component is tumor specific.
So as soon as you start using two inhibitors, you're going to make normal tissue-
Okay
... sensitive. So that wouldn't be the strategy I would take.
Okay. And also, I did work with Jerry Bartok and Thomas
Halliday, and actually discussing with Thomas, he
always
thinks that olaparib can be used in the patient as a maintenance
therapy, not as the new adjuvant or adjuvant therapy.
What is your view about this?
Not for the first time I disagree with Thomas.
We had a paper in "Nature Communications" with Gene Abram,
where olaparib was given with neoadjuvant chemotherapy
in triple-negative breast cancer,
BRCA-mutated tumor patients, 100% survival.
Small numbers, 39 out of 39
still alive. One progression-
Wow
... during that time.
So clearly there's an opportunity to use it in combination earlier.
And I also think that
with olaparib in maintenance, we've got the SOLO-1
data and the long-term follow-up with that.
I think induction can be possible if, for example, you've
debulked the tumors. What we find is that PARP inhibitors tend to work
better on smaller tumors. So that's sort of an
option as well. But I don't think you should just say it's
only useful
for maintenance. And then obviously there's also the potential to combine PARP
inhibitors with things like anti-androgen receptor inhibitors
in an induction scenario.
Okay.
So lots of
opportunities, and then we could talk about ADC Top1 combinations.
Mm-hmm.
So clinically,
any drug, if you're giving it up front, is going to work
better because you're dealing with a more homogenous
tumor, a less heavily pre-treated tumor, a patient
who's potentially fitter. And so that is the
reason why many drugs are being moved up front, and we do see that
patient benefit goes up, right? So clinically, it will always make
sense. And ultimately we want to move promising
therapies up front as much as possible, and that's
always the goal.
And if you have a pill that works
with efficacy, and that is importantly well-tolerated,
that is the ideal drug to try and bring up front in the
maintenance setting, whether it's new adjuvant, whether it's adjuvant.
So it makes sense what he said, but that's true for any drug
in theory, right? Again, depending on the pharmacology, the class, and
what ultimately you're trying to achieve.
So he's not completely wrong, but again, we've already seen, as
Mark has said,
approvals of PARP inhibitors in prostate cancer in the
relapse setting. We've seen it approved in breast cancer in the
relapse setting. So
Mark is right as well. There you go. How's that?
Good job.
He's much more diplomatic than I am.
Yes, please go ahead. Thank you.
So-- Excuse me.
The concepts of synthetic lethality can really help us bring
closer to curing cancer,
but it's the patient satisfaction in clinical trials that are really in the way.
If we look back at Latifi, for example,
what would be some of the takeaways that
why that trial
went wrong, and how to help bring that
drug into the market and prevent that failure that happened in the
past?
Can you elaborate on that?
Yeah. So
which part? The curing-
The failure of... You said the failure of Latitude?
Latifi.
The clinical trial for Latifi, right?
Mm-hmm.
Basically what happened was
the trials had enrolled patients,
and it was targeting DDR pathway,
but the cancer had escaped to PI3K, so
therefore,
the drug wasn't targeting the same pathway.
And I think that's one of the reasons because of replication stress-
Mm-hmm
... the trial,
the dilution rate was just far greater.
But that's just based on what I learned from
learning about Latifi. But...
I think it's a little bit more complicated than that.
And
I think there's evidence that the ATM deficient cohort patients
probably did better.
But the failure to meet the primary endpoint was in the ITT
population,
which would've been diluted. I think the other key difference
between Hudson, which was the
Phase II trial in small cell lung cancer where the original signal
had given
promise that led to the Phase III trial.
The other difference was that the comparator patient
population changed between the Phase II and the Phase III trial.
So in the Phase III trial,
more of the patients had had chemo and IO,
and actually the bar was raised in terms of theComparateur
arm response. So it was like
20/80 in the phase two and 80/20 in the phase three.
So I think that's the other reason why there was less of a
benefit for that. And that's again, that's something that,
I mean, Tim will know better than me, but you have to try and predict what's
going to happen in the future. It's very difficult to the patient
population.
Can I?
You may.
Thank you.
So just to add to what Mark's already said, perhaps-- I
mentioned the three key considerations, right?
Wide enough therapies again, next,
a biomarker and combinations. The problem with
Leofi, I guess, is the biomarker piece, right?
And so if you look at other approaches, for example, if we take the
Arteos example
of their trial where they selected patients for ATM
IHC loss tumors, and they saw a 50% response rate
in ATM loss tumors.
And as Mark alluded to, on Leofi, the benefit
was seen in the ATM patients, the mutation patients,
right? So I do think perhaps it was the biomarker
piece that was missing potentially with that combination,
and that could have led to
the lack of efficacy and a negative, in
theory, trial, right? But I also want to make a bigger point
about clinical trials
because we're doing poorly in terms of enrolling patients onto clinical
trials. If we really want to raise that bar for all of our patients with
cancer
in the world, we have to get patients onto clinical trials.
If we want to
get patients novel, innovative treatments,
the only way to do that is through clinical trials.
And patients are getting benefit if they have alterations, and we can match
them with treatments. Right? I think we're doing poorly.
5% to 10% of patients are getting on trials.
It takes us five to 10 years to get a drug approved.
And so I would push back on your point about
clinical trials not being great. I think absolutely,
we have patients who are extremely happy
because they're being monitored very closely.
We treat each patient
with
close
scrutiny and monitor them very closely, right?
And their safety and efficacy is absolutely important.
And I think any clinicians in this room would agree with that, okay?
Thank you.
Go ahead, Rob.
Hey, Tim. Thanks. I'm Rob Haromis from UT Health San
Antonio. Two questions for the entire panel.
The first question is, in our hands, ATR inhibitors
are effective in ATM mutant GI cancers but not in mantle cell
lymphoma. And so there's really some differences between the ATM mutant
cancers, and it'd be interesting if anyone could parse those out.
And then the second question is,
the recent Arteos data is intriguing with the ATR inhibitors
in the low-dose irinotecan, but that really opens up a
whole new
Pandora's box of how do we get two different
targeted agents into one cancer cell, and that's where ADCs
are fascinating. But I wonder if the panel had any other ideas on how to
specifically target, say, topone inhibitors and a
replication stress inhibitor
to a single cancer cell. So those two questions. Thanks.
Let me take the first part of that first.
So together with
colleagues from Arteos, we at MD Anderson
published the relationship between ATM mutations
and ATM IHC loss. And interestingly, we found that with
colorectal cancer, if you had an ATM mutation, you're more likely to
have protein loss as well. But there
was a context-specific effect. What I
mean by that was that the canonical cancers like breast, ovarian,
prostate, and colorectal cancer had
that relationship, but there were many other cancers that did not.
And so I think in answer to your question, I think the other cancer does
not have that kind of functional-
Mantle cell
... consequence of mutation to protein
loss, if you like. Did you want to take the second question?
Yes. Well, even commenting on the first bit.
So I think my understanding is that in mantle cell
lymphoma, it's loss of 11Q,
and then you have a second
sort of loss of heterozygosity or a second mutation.
Right.
And that second mutation may not be giving you complete deficiency.
Okay.
So that's another one.
All right. There may be some residual.
And then to answer your second question, I see the combination
of the ATR inhibitor plus low-dose irinotecan really as,
in ATM loss cancers, as a triple attack, right?
Or I call it triple attract because it's ATR, so attract.
Get it?
Har, har.
But anyway, triple attract because number one, you're bringing in
cancers with ATM loss, so potentially high replication stress.
Number two, you're going in with low-dose irinotecan to really damage and
kill those cancers, and then you're coming in with the ATR inhibitor to really
stop the recovery from high replication stress, right?
So you're really sustaining that with this triple approach.
And so that's the thinking, I guess, behind that.
In terms of the ADCs, I mentioned earlier now there are
these dual payload ADCs of etecan plus ATR
inhibitors
that are out there. There's one from Calio Therapeutics, which is a HER2 targeting
dual payload ADCAnd also CrossBridge
Bio, and I think Eli Lilly now
has acquired that drug,
which has, again, a dual payload, actually Tcan plus
ATR and episode. And that's a Trop-2 ADC as well.
So maybe that's a better way of delivering that.
I just wonder if there are any other specifically targeted agent
modalities that any of you have run across besides the ADCs.
I think the other thing as well is it depends on the combination.
So for a PARP inhibitor plus a TOP1 ADC agent,
our experience is that you want to be able to give gap scheduling.
So you want time for the bone marrow
damage caused by the ADC TOP1 to recover before you essentially expose
it to PARP inhibitor.
You can't really do that effectively on a dual payload with PARP and
TOP1. So I think there'll be some scenarios where it's fine and other scenarios
where you might want to have more ability to schedule, in which case, you might not
want them on the same molecule.
Sure. That's a good point.
And
there is a review out in "Cell" this week that actually covers
that concept of
gap scheduling.
Weren't you there first of all? Is that the one I owned the last of?
Kind of a generic question for the panel, but if we had to
go back and look at some of these targets, would you still call them synthetic
lethal? I guess, an ATR inhibitor or ATM inhibitor,
just their effect, their broad tox effects or effects on healthy cells,
are they synthetic lethal, you still think?
Great question.
So an ATM inhibitor is pretty well tolerated on its own, less so an
ATR inhibitor.
The
synthetic lethality, I think, has to really be driven
by a tumor deficiency that gives you a big enough window.
So you can be talking about the same type of inhibitor, but in different
tumor backgrounds, you might not have that level of therapeutic
window than in the other one. So I agree it's not straightforward.
But I do think there are examples where you might be able to get that synthetic
lethality. But what we've talked about is that it's not just the starting
point,
where you have the potential for a therapeutic window.
It's then having the pharmacology
to deliver that in a way that gives you that
wide therapeutic window as well. So I think the reason we haven't seen other
examples make it all the way through yet to the clinic is because it's not
straightforward.
Thanks.
Wonderful. Well, I'm sure everyone's hungry. Who wants lunch?
Thank you all for being here, and I'll bring the session to a close.
I want to thank Mark and Steve for being here. Thank you, everyone.